bonjour à tous je suis très heureux
d'être parmi vous merci beaucoup de
m'accueillir aujourd'hui vous êtes dans
une grande école de commerce
moi quand j'étais gamin je foutais rien
à l'école je m'emmerdais je peux
pourquoi je n'étais pas à ma place quand
j'étais adolescent je voulais être
prêtre pendant deux ans de ma vie entre
12 et 14 ans je voulais être prêtre je
suis issu d'une famille catholique du
nord de la france et j'ai été très
marqué par les valeurs qu'on m'a
enseignées enfants non pas que je
voulais finir dans une église ou dans un
monastère mais mais les valeurs de
partage enseigner parlera pas par le par
la religion m'ont beaucoup marqué à
l'époque je voulais éradiquer la
pauvreté dans le monde c'est un autre
des objectifs que je m'étais donné je
suis pas franchement pas revenu mais
pendant deux ans je voulais être prêtre
et je peux vous dire que c'est assez
contrarié en grandvaux copains veulent
être pilote de course ou architectes
vous dire moi j'ai envie d'être prêtre
je n'osais pas le dire
et puis ça m'a passé après j'ai aperçu
qu'à côté de jésus-christ vers un autre
truc était sympa aussi c'étaient les
jeunes femmes et donc pendant qu'est
pendant quelques mois j'ai été balancés
entre eux entre les deux pendant un
certain temps j'ai pensé que peut-être
je pouvais convaincre d'église
d'accepter le mariage des prêtres
mais ça ça non plus ça n'a pas marché
donc j'ai un peu abandonné mon idée et
puis j'ai suivi mes études toujours sans
bosser jusqu'au jour où où il m'est
arrivé pas malde aventure qui m'ont fait
évoluer vers ce que j'ai créée
aujourd'hui d'après ce que vous
connaissez l'inventeur du kitesurf qui
connaît leur inventeur de kitesurf
personne témoin
quand j'avais 15 ans donc un camp de la
prêtrise mais tu es passé j'avais dans
le nord de la france mes parents avaient
une maison à la mer et donc on avait
levé le paysage devant moi donc c'était
la plage sauf que régulièrement en
vacances j'avais un mes cousins que je
n'aimais pas du tout je citerai pas ce
que si le vois je mais je n'étais pas
très pote avec un de mes cousins
germains et mon cousin germain passer
son temps sur la plage avec un énorme
il avait deux ans de plus que moi avec
un énorme cerfs-volants et puis je veux
c'est un volant et ça gâche et mon
paysage parce que moi j'avais la merde
j'avais mon cousin j'avais pas qui était
juste devant s'améliorer et et un jour
je me suis dit mais si je lui mettais
une planche sous les pieds il serait
tirée par le vent et dégagerait nos
paysages et ce jour là je me suis bien
en fait
dans le nord la famille mulliez auchan
décathlon etc je dis bien on pourrait
peut-être en fait inventé ce produit un
cerf-volant une planche on met ça sur
l'eau qui on étire est ça pourrait être
vachement amusant et pendant des mois je
me suis dit tiens comment pourrait
construire ce truc là etc
et puis j'avais pas réussi à régler le
problème la direction je n'arrêtais pas
de bloquer sur un gros problème qui
était dit oui mais si on est embarqué au
large on sait plus revenir mais ça m'a
travaillé longtemps et puis après je
suis passé à autre chose
je pense souvent mes idées
jusqu'au jour où j'ai découvert le
premier kitesurf et le jour où j'ai vu
le premier cas search aussi mère d'un
c'est moi qu'il avait inventé
vous l'avez compris je n'ai pas inventé
de kitesurf dans ma tête j'ai inventé et
ça a été l'une de mes premières grandes
les premières grandes frustrations de ma
vie que j'avais inventé un truc un autre
mec que moi a fait avait en fait inventé
en vrai et je me suis je ne me ferai pas
avoir une deuxième fois et si j'avais
une autre occasion comme ça une bonne
idée cette fois ci je le ferai et en
fait ce jour-là donc à 15 ans je me suis
aperçu aussi que j'étais un peu
entrepreneurs au fond de moi et
entrepreneurs on l'a dit déjà ici
entrepreneurs s'est trouvé une idée et
trouver une idée c'est pas toujours
aussi évident que ça moi la mienne je
les trouvais au final à 41 ans en fait
trouvé une idée quand vous êtes
entrepreneur dans l'âme
c'est un peu comme me savuth une
expérience que j'ai tout vécu c'est
quand vous visitez un appartement vous
cherchez un appartement vous allez en
visite et 50
ce sont que des daubes ils sont tous
moches là c'est horrible à vous êtes
obligé de dire qui est bien parce que il
ya dix personnes qui en dehors mais en
fait les appartements ce match est le
51e
vous avez à peine ouvert la porte que
vous savez que c'est celui là vous avez
vécu ça
ben moi c'est ce qui est bien
l'entrepreneuriat c'est un peu ça et moi
c'est ce qui m'est arrivé en 2006 quand
j'ai rencontré au tadjikistan madame
karimov lalanne karimov c'est une
bénéficiaires de micro crédit j'étais
banquier pendant 12 ans banquier de
gestion de fortune je m'occupais de gens
très fortunés et j'ai eu la chance de
rencontrer madame karimov une
bénéficiaire de microcrédit une femme à
qui on prêtait 350 euros pour le pour
développer sa petite activité
d'autosubsistance sortir de la pauvreté
faire vivre toute sa famille moi je
travaillais dans les banques de gestion
de fortune dans l'est dans l'est dans
les beaux quartiers de paris boulevard
haussmann je m'occupais de gens qui ont
entre 1 et 100 millions d'euros et je me
suis retrouvé devant madame karimov qui
pendant une heure d'abord elle m'a
accueilli comme ça elle m'a accueilli à
pieds nus ça m'était jamais arrivé avec
mes clients et pendant une heure elle me
faisait sourire jusqu'aux oreilles et
elle me remerciait toutes les trois
minutes du crédit de 350 euros qu'on lui
faisait jamais un mes clients fortunés
ne m'avait remercier du bon travail que
je faisais dans des banques de gestion
de fortune et ça ça a été ma grande
claque et surtout après être revenu du
tadjikistan j'ai découvert sur un
article de journal un article de
courrier international j'ai découvert un
article sur le site internet qui va je
sais pas si vous connaissez qui va un
site de financement participatif de
microcrédit et ce jour là ça a été moi
ma 51e porte ce jour là je me suis dit
merde
ce site internet est génial j'ai vu
madame karimov ya pas très longtemps
j'adore cette histoire du microcrédit
cette finance du sourire cette finance
fondamentalement utile et je vais lancer
mon entreprise à moi ça y est mon
kite-surf je le tiens je vais lancer un
site de financement participatif de
microcrédit et c'est comme ça que
l'histoire de babylon ad mare est gênant
c'est donc babylon qui est devenu
le plus gros sites européens de
crowdfunding de microcrédit le deuxième
plus gros après les américains ils sont
cinquante fois plus gros que d'eau mais
néanmoins et surtout quand j'ai lancé
babylon je me suis dit qui va à
l'américain c'est une ong c'est une
association qui traite d'un sujet
d'intérêt général
le microcrédit l'éradication de la
pauvreté etc
moi c'est pas mon truc je voulais dit
j'avais envie de créer une start up
j'avais envie de créer une entreprise et
je me suis dit pourquoi on ne pourrait
pas créé ce truc là sous forme d'une
start-up ce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui
une start up social
aujourd'hui vous connaissez le sujet de
l'intérêt général
le sujet de la précarité de la pauvreté
qui s'en occupe aujourd'hui c'est l'état
c'est les associations c'est le monde de
l'économie sociale et solidaire le monde
de l'économie sociale et solidaire
l'état providence c'est aujourd'hui 10%
du pib en france c'est 13 % des emplois
des salariés qui s'occupent de traiter
des problématiques d'intérêt général
l'exclusion la pauvreté et la précarité
etc
c'est l'état qui subventionne les
associations un million cent mille
associations en france qui sont
subventionnées par l'état par la
défiscalisation ce sont les entreprises
d'insertion
l'état paye des subventions pour
permettre à des entreprises d'intérêt
des gens nos déjà en situation
d'exclusion
ce sont les coopératives ce sont les
fondations c'était tout cet univers de
l'économie sociale et solidaire nul 1-1
univers énorme engagé et militant
passionnant c'est ce monde qui traite
l'intérêt général ce ne sont pas les
start up mais moi je me retrouvais pas
dans ce monde là je voulais créer mass
start up sur un sujet d'intérêt général
le microcrédit bien quand j'ai vu qu'il
va en ong je me suis non moi je veux pas
faire une nouvelle riche de fermat start
up et je me suis dit que peut-être
qu'avec cet outil de crowdfunding
microcrédit on pouvait en faire une
start up et c'est comme ça qu'on a créé
une start-up une start up social qu'est
ce que c'est qu'une start up social
c'est une entreprise commerciale comme
les autres
qui doit trouver son modèle économique
qui doit trouver son marché qui doit
trouver son marketing qui doit trouver
ses clients qui doit trouver sa
rentabilité
sa pérennité qui va peut-être se
valoriser un jour qui vaudra quelque
chose mais qui surtout va s'emparer d'un
sujet d'intérêt général
et c'est ça qui fait la différence avec
une autre start-up et bien aujourd'hui
moi je suis convaincu que les start up
social sont probablement l'une des
solutions à l'avenir du traitement de la
solidarité en france
tout ce monde de l'économie sociale et
solidaire souffre beaucoup aujourd'hui
les subsides de l'état n'arrête pas de
baisser il ya plus d'argent dans les
caisses
alors que en face de ça les problèmes de
la précarité
l'élévation du niveau de la pauvreté etc
les problèmes en france ne cesse
d'augmenter avec un état qui a de moins
en moins d'argent à affecter au monde de
l'économie sociale et solidaire
comment faire eh bien je suis convaincu
que moi que ces start up social qui
demandent rien personne si ce n'est que
de trouver leur marché et bien sont
capables de prendre de prendre le relais
du traitement de l'intérêt général en
tout cas le relais d'une partie du
traitement de l'intérêt général
alors vous allez me dire c'est
sympathique mais c'est pas évident oui
c'est pas évident
cd modèle économique compliqué mais le
jour où on arrivera à développer plus
qu'aujourd'hui les start up social
aujourd'hui en a allez je vous ai dit un
million cent mille associations en
france il ya trente start up social y en
a que vous connaissez au delà de babylon
des entreprises comme l oas au micro
dont vous avez plein de petites start-up
qui émerge de la part de deux jeunes
diplômés comme vous qui veulent créer
une entreprise qui veut créer une
entreprise ici
d'accord un tiers peut-être il y en a
plein d'étudiants aujourd'hui qui
veulent créer des des entreprises des
petits start up social des des boîtes
qui vont faire de la des visites
touristiques à paris par des sdf des
épiceries solidaires qui peut être
rentable avec un petit modèle économique
tout un tas de nouveaux modèles qui
émergent
il y en a 30 aujourd'hui je suis sûr que
dans les années qui viennent on pourrait
avoir des milliers de start up social
qui s'occupe de l'intérêt général sans
rien demander à personne formidable
moyen de traiter plus encore aujourd'hui
des questions d'intérêt général par des
start up mieux formidable pour l'état
développer les start-ups official c'est
tres et traiter un sujet d'intérêt
général sans que ça coûte un centime
puisque les startups les startups
trouvent leurs financeurs trouvent leur
modèle économique
donc c'est une aubaine incroyable pour
l'état c'est une aubaine aussi pour vous
le tiers d'entre vous qui veut créer une
entreprise
on parle on n'arrête pas de nous parler
de la génération x y z etc
mais moi j'ai envie de penser à une
autre génération la génération s la
génération des jeunes qui veulent donner
du sens à leur carrière du sens à leur
vie et qui en même temps envie de créer
une entreprise
c'est un mariage parfait j'ai envie de
vous proposer
soyez une génération est une génération
sociale mais surtout une génération
d'entrepreneurs sociaux au sens start up
social
voilà ce que je voulais vous dire
aujourd'hui vous avez on est on est peu
de chose dans la vie et le fait de
pouvoir concilier la passion l'intérêt
général avec l'entrepreneuriat
je suis pas sûr qu'ils aient quelque
chose de mieux
c'est absolument passionnant je me dis
souvent quand je vois on est peu de
chose
l'autre jour baptiste baptiste et un
jeune de 33 ans qui a travaillé trois
ans chez labit lawn
il est décédé d'une crise cardiaque
talent et à son enterrement la semaine
dernière et je me dis que la vie est
fragile et souvent je me dis qu'entre
je roule à 80 kilomètres à l'heure avec
mon scooter pour ne pas arriver en
retard à l'ieseg et que je manque de
mourir sur le périph quand je suis
fatiguée parce que développe une start
up social
c'est fatiguant comme tous les preuves
comme tous les projets qu'on peut mener
dans la vie je me dis mais est ce que je
suis prêt à partir et chaque fois la
réponse qui me vient en tête c'est la
même c'est-à-dire non j'ai pas encore
assez apporté ma pierre et bien je vais
continuer à apporter ma pierre en
développant babylon en créant d'autres
start up social et vraiment je vous
invite à réfléchir à ce joli sujet soyez
des start-up heures sociaux c'est une
vie passionnante et je vous invite à
vous lancer là dedans peut être vous
aussi avec nous merci beaucoup